[Music]
so you get benefit to the gene from you
checker here and this video was
initially going to be called the overdub
on video where I was going to spend some
time trying to get a low-level account
with no money at all to trying it
themselves to kill Hill Giants and then
kill over where the Giants which is a
free to my boss or this hill giant Club
which are right now is around 1 mil I
was going to I was going to do this
video and kind of I hope to see how this
boss might play out for free to my
players but after killing over a couple
of times
and camping hell giants and learned a
couple of things about this which I'm
not going to show it till the end of the
video but for now why don't we go ahead
and see all the loops I got from the 28
kills from oh boy
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guys here we are
so always buddy is showing an average
loot around 1.4 million but why don't we
go ahead and see how much all this
really is
[Music]
okay so always buddies showing around
1.3 milk is what this entire Luca
showing but obviously take out the meat
they'll join Club it drops down to
around 400,000 that's with 28 or war
kills now at the beginning of this video
I said I'd learned some things out
telling a bore and he'll giant in
general now when it comes to the loot I
think I think I guess it's in a perfect
place for free to play I know with Jagex
and pretty boy players obviously they're
going to be limited upon the kind of
access they to have I think it's the
thing it's perfectly balanced in terms
of a free to play boss one of our one of
our sponsors actually flipping old
school has made a wide variety of videos
from the low level account free-to-play
accounts and pay to play accounts level
3 no money whatsoever starting the game
with absolutely nothing and then getting
a bond within a short period of time now
if this is something that if you want to
get yourself to a member as quickly as
possible and I'll absolutely by watching
some of his videos you guys know how to
do that but in terms of killing hell
gems to get to a bond
I'm very iffy on that I don't know if
it's actually worth while I strongly
believe that if you just kind of
followed some of his videos or some of
the other videos that some of our other
sponsors have made you'll get yourself
to a bond much quicker than trying to
kill whole board per body and the
biggest reason for this was the amount
of time that it took to actually get a
giant key the quickest way to get time
keys if you don't know if you're a
free-to-play player is to kill the hill
giants of the wilderness now I don't I
didn't camp the keys and the wilderness
in a free player world I camp them in a
members world but still I was getting
peak aid every maybe 5-10 minutes
so I only brought three items so I
wouldn't lose anything but it was kind
of annoying having a contingency run
back and forth between the bank and and
to the hill guys in wilderness and I
can't imagine how often that areas
became I'm free to play but that's
something also to in mind also you're
not going to get there as quickly as I
was because I could just use a game
necklace teleport to corporal be Slayer
I'm there in like three seconds whereas
free deployed player it might take you
like two minutes to get there so that's
something to consider today guys I mean
in the end if you want to kill Hill
Giants and you end up getting a giant
key then yeah absolutely go for it go
kill kill kill
oh boy and see if you can get a he'll
drown Club other than that if you're a
free-to-play member freedom a player and
you want to get it up to members as
quickly as possible I strongly advise
watching our partnership videos and
getting yourself to a member quickly as
possible because there's a whole lot
more money making methods as a member as
opposed to free to buy player and solely
relying on this it's just not worthwhile
it is just really not I know that
400,000 might seem like a lot to some of
those critical players but the amount of
time it took to camp those keys was a
long time and if you were to get
yourself a member you'd be able to make
that any much quicker timeframe but
other than that guys I think that's the
end of the video be sure to stay tuned
for another video that I'm coming out
with very soon I'm already working on it
it's gonna be kind of like a new series
for you guys I hope you guys enjoyed but
other than that you guys like this video
we should leave a like down below to
share your support be sure to subscribe
for future content we sure leave a
comment down below TBM your thoughts
good luck merchandise and until
[Music]
Oh